the jurgen experience um
see i don't have a desired outcome i
mean i would love it if aliens were real
okay but when someone starts talking
about disinformation and propaganda
campaigns but they want you to believe
them right but don't listen i'm here
telling you the truth i'm here telling
you the truth
i'm not saying i'm telling you the truth
at all that's why i was not you know
let's wait for
hour three because it's too explosive
people have such a horse in the race
yeah already
with aliens you think well i mean maybe
you are
neutral i don't know i know i'm neutral
yeah
i will listen i absolutely want aliens
to be real
100 wouldn't it be interesting that's
not i'm not neutral but i
am neutral in my perceptions and when i
look at things i
i go hmm i don't know about that me too
i want to see a picture
like what are these what do these guys
look like i mean what did they do to
them did he describe
what kind of surgical alterations i
stayed with the source
i mean after the book published i would
go and visit him we'd sit in a chinese
restaurant and eat and talk and i would
try to get a droplet of information out
of him
what was he doing oh my god he avoided i
mean look here's another thing when the
book came out his wife of 65 years knew
it was him
okay and i went out to las vegas and sat
there in a room
with the source and his wife and she
said
tell me this isn't true tell me you made
this all up to her husband
and he said it's the truth
i mean that's a triangular version of
getting at the truth but
again to reiterate i believe he believes
what he told me was the truth that was
the truth he was told
i think there's certain agents that
think it's fun to [ __ ] with reporters
and journalists
and make things up i really do and i
think especially when they're talking
about
secret information that they were sworn
to protect and then all of a sudden
they want to talk to someone that they
don't even know on the sneak tip
let's meet at a diner i'm going to tell
you everything that's not how we met
well i mean yeah i mean however you met
yeah well we met
because i was interviewing
nuclear weapons engineers who are
setting off nuclear bombs
in area 51 mushroom i mean in the nevada
test site area 12 area 23.
and they all said to me you've got to
talk to the top
engineer of all this weaponry and they
gave me his name
and we talked for days and hours about
nuclear weapons
and then in one conversation
he began to cry and told me this story
that i was like
what why was he crying he was crying
because
he participated in our version of the
human experiments
because what the russians do we do it
look i've written five books about that
we
altered people to make them look like
aliens according to him we had a small
program
in 1951 where we wanted to see how the
russians did what they did
how they made human beings look like
this so what'd they do take prisoners or
something
like what who they alter he said they
were handicapped children oh jesus
and he told me that he participated in
this so again i mean unless you have
someone that lost their mind at age 90
and was willing to tell their wife of 65
years i lost my mind
so he's saying that he participated in
something that altered handicapped
children when you say handicapping like
down syndrome or something like that
and they made them look like aliens and
then killed them
like what did how did they what did they
do with this this is where we get into
drops of information
but what i can say is he had a
grandchild that was born that way
and and the grandchild did not live long
the grandchild died
and it made him feel so guilty about
what he had done
that he felt compelled to con to confess
if he will and i remember saying to him
why are you telling me this why don't
you tell a priest and he said
a priest would judge me and i can tell
you won't why wouldn't you judge them i
judge them
well i guess that's why i'm a born
journalist joe because i
really try not to judge people i mean my
new book surprise kill vanish it's about
assassins it's about
people who work for the cia who do what
needs to be done
on the ground uh in the name of national
security
i don't judge them this is why you know
what's really at issue here is morality
right
yeah i mean can i tell you how i got the
idea
for this book sure but let me before we
go any further so
you want to talk about that yeah yeah
was he saying
that there have never been any
encounters with
alien spacecraft he was totally neutral
about aliens he had nothing to do with
aliens he could have cared less he
didn't watch the x-files
and what was his take on bob lazar his
take on bob lazar was that he probably
saw
something that the government had an
extension of the program i mean he
didn't know that was speculative we
didn't talk about that i mean
you know other than inference he was
very limited
in his in the information that he would
get out but
i mean i used 79 sources in that book
that all went on the record in name
and he was the one anonymous source
because
but like i said you know he told me
after he died that i
could tell the whole story are you going
to i might i might come back write
another book
well if you give me a break and back off
of this subject i might come back and
tell you
and you're honest this is your book i
want to promote your book i know you
want to promote your new book but i want
to promote this book as well
i mean i'm teasing you right now but
it's
it's like it's an astonishing
story and i think the best line of all
is that people that read about that in
the very end of what we did they go i
wish they were aliens
um you know so stalin
created some sort of a craft that mimics
you're going to read it okay
that's what you're going to do the rest
of the afternoon nope i'm going to come
back on your
podcast and we're talking i i think we
should probably get into this a little
bit okay
come on with a question okay i'm used to
asking the questions are you oh right as
a journalist
yeah now stalin and the the russians
created something that mimicked
um a ufo something that looked like it
would be from another planet is that
what they did
mothership in those days drones were
there was a mothership and a drone was
attached to it and it was jettisoned off
okay so in those days
well in 1947 48 what do you mean by
well they didn't i mean that was drone
technology then okay right so there's a
mother a mother
craft like an aircraft and then the
drone is like a small
aircraft under it and it gets jettisoned
off
and that was what the craft was it was
jettisons off so that so stalin actually
according to the source invaded our
airspace which was the deep
embarrassment to truman
so we invaded our airspace and then let
this drone
crash land on the ground with these
things
that turned out to be human they looked
like aliens but they turned out to be
humans that were manipulated
surgically to look like aliens yes as a
way to and remember
i mean not remember but where where this
was was
you know very close to a nuclear weapons
base to our
white sands military base i mean this is
like not a place you want the russians
to be able to get near
right you know i mean what was
interesting is at area 51 we then went
out and mimicked all of those
one of our early drones was a mimicry of
that it was the d2
there was a m21 which was the mother
ship and a d21 which was the
daughter ship so how do they pilot them
was it
wirelessly like we do now no no then it
was like there was a pilot in the mother
ship and they kind of let it go right
and it flew off i mean there's
incredible stories of what the cia was
able to do out there
at area 51 with their air branch you
know
um the technology they're always ahead
of technology that's
remarkable well what bob lazar did film
that was really shocking was the
film the filming of these drones flying
around
and performing these really cra you've
seen those videos i'm sure
in the 80s it gets really crazy with
what they're able to do and what they're
but i mean why i like looking at history
is because you can see the progression
you know you see how science
evolves you know bit by bit and then
there's these great
breakthroughs because what the
government is always looking for
is called a revolution in military
affairs right and that's certainly what
drone technology did
um later on as drones became developed
after the vietnam war
so in the 1980s when bob lazar was
filming all this stuff
you think this was similar to the
technology that we see
publicly described today in terms of
like what drones are capable of
sure i mean that's probably had
something like that back then there oh
you know when
when the f-117 was revealed during the
first gulf war
that aircraft was being developed for 20
25 years out at area 51
actually at area 52 was where they had
it set up
to develop that stealth technology think
about and
what was amazing talk about keeping
secrets they had something like
10 000 people working on that
no one knew about it that story was
never broken by the press not by anyone
it just suddenly appeared in the gulf
war and took out saddam hussein's
you know facilities that's a revolution
in military affairs what becomes
interesting is then it becomes obsolete
because now everybody knows about it and
everybody's going to mimic that
and now you have to have a new weapon
system and that's the
military-industrial complex
so was this drone aircraft that was
released from the mothership was this
capable of autonomous flight
or was it just they just threw it out
there and let it crash
the latter right and remember that
information i am very limited to that's
why it's 12 pages it's like
the source gave me these little bits of
information
which i felt i felt was important to
include because it
speaks to the big issue why is area 51
classified i mean now it's not president
obama was the first president to
actually say
area 51 publicly some people say because
of my book
right meaning it was out the secret was
out but before that i went through 10
000 pages of documents from the national
archives
and every place you see the word area 51
was actually redacted right why would
you keep that so secret i mean
all the guys that i was interviewing say
they could call it you know groom lake
they could call it the test facility
they could call it paradise ranch
but they couldn't say area 51 why
and the source said well because we did
this horrible program out there and the
government doesn't want
anyone to know about that ever i mean
there's stories of like
somebody asking bill clinton you know
about area 51 him going white
i mean human experiments who wants to be
part of that that's horrible but the
human experiments were
were they limited to this mimicry of the
russian experience where they were
trying to get people to look like aliens
or there's something else going on oh my
goodness i mean you read
now the declassified documents tell us
how many
different human experiments were going
on around
nuclear weapons okay horrible
experiments where they were subjecting
people to radiation
because they wanted to know they felt
well it's more important to know what
happens to people than to not know and
so
they would take groups of people that
say had cancer or something and test
them so there's no doubt that the
government
has experimented on humans it's just
is that something that is wise to make
public
and you know there's two sides of the
coin on that i mean you you
when you reveal these kind of things
when you write about them i mean people
get really upset and you know
vilify the government partially with
good reason and partially it's like
bad for national security so i think
that's the justification on the part of
the defense department to keep things
secret
that makes sense wow that's uh it's an
interesting take that i never thought of
before but
if i was stalling and i was trying to
air quotes [ __ ] with the americans
that's maybe where i would do it hey man
you got
problems aliens they're coming and there
was if people
it's hard for people that live in 2019
especially if you're young
to really imagine a world not only
without the internet
but with two television channels right
and
radio which was where people got all
their information from i mean was there
two channels how many channels were
in 1947 maybe three maybe
maybe maybe three i mean it was radio in
world war ii right most people had radio
yeah mostly radio and newspapers and
that's where people were getting their
information
and there was a mass hysteria where
people were
absolutely terrified that we were going
to be invaded
which is why when orson welles war of
worlds which
when they released it when they did it
on the air they were
very clear that this is going to be
a reading of orson welles war of worlds
book or that uh h.g wells excuse me war
of war right was ht wells book and orson
welles read
it yes and when they were talking about
this
on the radio a lot of people missed that
part right and so
as the radio went on as the broadcast
went on and people were tuning in later
in the day
it erupted in mass hysteria people were
freaking out hundreds of thousands of
people
really did think that it was and it was
also something
that was recreated in other countries i
don't know if you know that they did
that in other countries in different
languages when they
saw how cute it worked in america and
you know so you see
you can see the logic i mean at first it
sounds absurd and it sounds ridiculous
and that's why i was sweating because
it's like i know right right
but when you think it through and i
challenge you to read the whole book
because you start piecing together
these various ideas and disinformation
becomes less vague and more specific and
you go ah
that's how it works and you begin to see
how
people's perception and how they're
easily manipulated
factors into national security just like
you just described
stalin knew about that he was a master
he was the master of propaganda he
invented it i mean he didn't invent it
but he invented it
in a you know on the political stage
to be used to mess with another
country's perception of things
think of what he did with brainwashing
right okay so like in the 50s and this
is journalist you know said
so there was a journalist who was
putting out stories about brainwashing
and
there was this idea which is well taken
that totalitarian governments brainwash
people and this became a big code word
it was
introduced into the american lexicon in
well then we're in the korean war our
pilots start getting shot down
they're put on tv by the communists
saying
terrible things about america the
american pilots
and suddenly it was like they've been
brainwashed it was very convenient to
have that story
so these things work part and parcel and
you've got all kinds of smart people
behind the scenes
knowing this looking at it examining it
and
using it to their advantage to stay
where
in the poll position that's the goal of
the us government
so the propaganda that we did
that sort of copied stalin we were kind
of playing catch-up in that sense
i mean we're playing catch-up then we're
ahead we're behind
it's always a it's a game it's i mean
you're a competitor you know this
that's a crazy thing to do to make a
fake spaceship
and just let it slam into the ground
with a bunch of people that you
cut up to look like aliens did he say
specifically what kind of modification
they made to people that made them look
like aliens
i got drips you'll read it in those
twelve come on with this 12 pages
i'm telling you that because you're
asking me these questions as if i
spent i mean look i did spend literally
hundreds of hours with this source
we sat there and talked about everything
and i would try to squeeze out just like
you're trying to squeeze out of me and
that's what i'm saying read it because i
literally tell you
everything that there is i think what's
most interesting about the source and
why i
might come back and talk to you about it
and tell you who he is on your show
is because because of his
backstory right why he did what he did
how he wound up in the manhattan project
sounds like he was probably jewish from
germany
no no no i'm trying okay
trying to get you